I was talking on the phone with my
brother who's stationed and Fort Bragg
and they have a 9:00 p.m. curfew what on
earth is a 9:00 p.m. curfew doing to
stop the spread of a pandemic bars are
already closed this doesn't make any
sense this is just something for for for
simple-minded people to express how much
they did do to combat the pandemic you
didn't do anything you infringed on
people's freedoms for no reason you have
to have a good reason for implementing
the restrictions that people are going
to implement I'm Dave Rubin and this is
the Rubin report reminder guys you can
get all of our episodes days early and
totally ad-free at Rubin report com and
joining me today is a former Navy SEAL
the congressman from Texas is 2nd
district and author of fortitude
American resilience in the era of
outrage congressman Dan Crenshaw finally
welcome to the Rubin report it great to
be with you Dave
we've been trying to pull this off for a
long time but I guess it took it took a
pandemic to it for us to accept Skype as
the only way we could make it happen
yeah that's true I was supposed to come
through LA for my book tour as you know
we had some events planned together but
you know life happens life happens
indeed it does all right well let's
start with the stuff that we got to get
out of the way no matter what before we
get into the book and your story and
everything else which is just
coronavirus sort of where we're at I'm
really curious your thoughts on the
stimulus package and the way we watched
it sort of unfold but just generally can
you talk about what it's like to be in
Congress right now in a time of truly
unprecedented happenings
yeah it's odd in the same way that it's
probably odd for everybody else you're
trying to continue doing your job
hopefully you still have your job and
but you're trying to do it from home
you're trying to to to be as effective
as you were before but you're but you're
doing it from home and that's that's
difficult more psychologically than
logistical e we can make an app in
logistically our office is still
operating as normal
the there's there's the frustrating
thing about how this has played out from
the Congressional standpoint is is how
the partisan games didn't really stop
and whereas we maybe thought they would
we I think I had some hope that they
would mostly because they they were
stopping to an extent I'll never forget
Chuck Schumer on TV that Saturday and
late February talking about how
bipartisan this rescue package was going
and it was going well good talks he said
he said surprisingly good bipartisan
talks and then it all blew up the next
day and he quickly shifted tax and and
and and went right along with policies
demands of this crazy progressive wish
list ultimately the the package went
through days later after millions of
jobs have been lost but ultimately went
through and it was basically the same
package anybody who argues otherwise is
being totally intellectually dishonest
you know the changes were minor and
could have been agreed to that weekend
prior that was extremely disappointing
that was also a turning point I think I
think we all noticed a turning point
right then that came from the left-wing
media and that that turning point was
Trump is to blame for millions of deaths
for now that's right that was the new
that was the that's been the new
narrative and it hasn't stopped
in fact it shifts slightly okay you know
you saw it shift from from saying hey
there's the Trump's travel restrictions
from China won't really travel
restrictions it was you know he could
have done more all right well that's a
dishonest talking point because the
reality is the people coming from China
after January 31st were American
citizens or green card holders so now
you're gonna have to explain to me why
we shouldn't be repatriating our own
citizens okay these are just really
disingenuous or remarks now the new
talking point is that they didn't do
anything in February okay fine so the
travel restriction was good we agree
with that even though we didn't at the
time and even though Democrats were in
charge they never would have put those
were travel restrictions then fine but
Trump didn't do anything to February
except for except deny the whole thing
again is this really an honest talking
point you know could it with 20/20
hindsight could we have done more yes
but with the facts that we had at the
time I question what what exactly you
think they should have done more PPE
production and ventilator production
more testing production I agree with all
that I just don't think it's I just
don't think it's reasonable to be
looking back in time and saying you made
this decision differently than I would
have made this decision is that true is
that the toughest part of doing what you
guys have to do in terms of preparing
for something like this because right
now the hindsight thing is just driving
me crazy when you hear it from the media
that oh suddenly they're saying
everybody knew this was coming in
February and it's like you know there
were I think three possibly four
Democratic debates in February the last
one in February I believe was February
25th it was gonna virus was not
mentioned in any of them it wasn't
mentioned until the one where they only
had Biden and Bernie in a room alone
because of coronavirus that was already
into March
so you see everybody it's like yeah now
that we see the score of the game yeah
we can tell you everything that you did
wrong before but that's not really how
you can prepare as a government a
hundred percent true i I'm about to
release a video on on this exact thing I
did a podcast on this and where I think
it was a week and a half ago where I
really I did 30 minutes of timeline on
exactly who is saying what at what time
I'm not trying to make excuses for Trump
here I I just want people to understand
the truth and you made another good
point I'd even bring up that point my
time line of like they weren't talking
about this nobody was talking about this
in late February Pelosi and de Blasio
we're telling people to go celebrate the
Chinese New Year go out don't be afraid
and I'm not blaming them they had the
same set of facts that we all did I
don't think they're responsible for
people's deaths either I think I I think
this is a bad situation that we didn't
quite expect I also point out you know
in Italy they didn't shut down their
society until March 10th Spain not until
March 14th
that's way later than February as it
turns out you know we did our 15 days to
slow the spread on March 16th Iran
didn't even start until April 4th Sweden
still hasn't started and probably never
will you know it's just these are really
disingenuous attacks and as it pertains
to something like P
even with hindsight you know it's not
obvious that the PPE shortage is going
to be there it's not like I think people
simplify what information government
officials truly have and are capable of
having it's not like it's not like
there's this final tally of n95 mass and
the government just knows what they are
and knows what they'll need well no I
mean hospitals are also responsible for
stockpiling in Houston were well
stockpiled maybe because we've been
through a lot of we've been through
pandemics before we've been through
hurricanes before our hospital system
operates a little bit differently than
maybe another hospital system that
doesn't feel they need a bunch of n95
massy that's not necessarily the federal
government's fault and again if we
really want to point fingers if we
really want to go down this road I will
point you to all the fact checkers that
have confirmed that it's really the
Obama administration that didn't
replenish our national stockpile then
what 95 mastered the h1n1 virus but
should I really blame them I mean that's
another question should I really be
playing blaming the Obama administration
what crystal ball do they have things
they spent it on radiological protection
and things like that you know there's no
ill intent here and now I will also
point out that our hospital systems have
been strained but not broken nobody has
been denied a ventilator
unlike in places in Europe why because
well it turns out our profit driven
healthcare system has an excess of
things like ventilators and ICU beds I I
went through the numbers on this on a
per capita basis the u.s. has way more
orders of magnitude more ICU beds and
ventilators than any of these Western
countries or countries in Europe any of
them including Germany and that's a
product of our health care system it's
an imperfect health care system I wish
there was different in a lot of ways but
socialized medicine means less supply
because you're basically setting price
controls and people need to understand
these basic facts as we as we judge what
could have been done and what should
have been done so I'm speaking of what
could have been done what should have
been done can you just explain a little
bit about how information actually gets
to you guys like how does it get to a
of Congress that say in January there's
sort of these initial reports of
something going on Trump does the
initial shutdown I think it was on jet
last day of January I think but like
when does something actually get to your
desk and how do you actually decide oh
now this is something I got to talk to
somebody about or do you pass it on to
somebody and say does this study make
sense or is anyone else see in these
reports like how does some of that
information actually turn into something
actionable yeah that's an interesting
question we don't have a whole lot of
secret lines of information that the
public doesn't have oftentimes members
of Congress are really operating off of
the same set of facts that most people
in the media are or most members of the
public the difference is we have sets of
professionals that we can rely on to
sift through all of the information and
and and place that against prior policy
compare that against prior legislation
and in talk about it in legislative
terms this is we we we have I just have
a team that helps me do that so that you
know I I'm not a I'm not a journalist
trying to do it all myself and so that's
a huge advantage as far as sifting
through the information and making sure
that we get it correct as far as what
you do with that information that that
can be wildly different for every member
of Congress every member of Congress is
representing their district and as such
they they tend to that didn't have
priorities and things that they think
that should be made more important than
other things and so because in theory in
theory a given member of Congress could
do nothing for two years there's no
there's not some obligatory schedule
that anybody is on right like in the
theory they don't even have to vote okay
I'm sure their constituents wouldn't
like that very much and they would vote
them out of office then in two years but
but it's really up to you I mean you've
got a lot of freedom as an elected
member to to prioritize and make things
happen accordingly and an information
comes to us again you know it can come
directly from the White House of course
especially being a Republican
it was a Democrat White House I would
hope that we would still see those kind
of things I know my Democrat colleagues
still get a lot of updates as well but
it's it's different for every issue yeah
and so that's why it's I'm kind of
fumbling that question a little bit
because there isn't a given set of rules
that that dictate how that information
flows it's it's relationships it's it's
you watching the media it's you seeing
what other members are saying and that's
talking to to industry to your
constituents it comes from all angles ya
know that actually does strike me as a
pretty clean and honest answer because I
think people think it's as if you guys
just all get a report in the morning and
then it's like oh now this is what we
got to do about this thing here but
before we move on from Corona though and
I want to obviously talk about the book
you mentioned the stimulus before and
can you just talk a little bit about
what that process is like and when you
suddenly see everybody on every side
although in this case I think the most
egregious examples were were by the
progressives about just all the pork
they stuff in there and all these things
that have nothing to do with helping the
economy because of coronavirus and then
it held
you know it's things like you know Nancy
Pelosi happens to be on the board of the
Kennedy Arts Center and like all of
these things that we all know are
terrible and when when limited
government people see those things it's
like man if you guys can't even help us
now if you can't even do it right now
then even the little bit of the limited
part starts to become really frickin
irrelevant you know yeah as far as the
process on this particular day and
unfortunately a lot of bills the it is a
closed group of leadership that's that's
doing that and that's for the sake of
expediency you that doesn't mean people
don't have a say there's there's a
constant conversation of and ways to get
input into there of course it's hard to
put input into a bill if you're not
really sure how the bill is being formed
anyway our leadership is a previous in
job of keeping us informed in a private
way so then maybe it's maybe it's
conference calls or whatever it is so
that we can say hold on we're not in
favor of this just like I was outspoken
against you know direct cash payment
I don't think then made any sense for a
lot of reasons and and in the same way
progressives and some more populist
conservatives were against any kind of
help to big to big businesses at all if
it's just loans and so people still get
their voice heard on that so but the
reality is is yes a lot of this is
negotiated in in closed-door sessions
and I'm not so sure that's the wrong way
because you know you could debate it
publicly on the House floor I suppose
but where would we get and how long
would that take when when this is an
emergency you know so that that's that
the whether that's good or bad is I
think truly up for debate as far as the
pork goes yeah it's frustrating you
didn't see me making a huge fuss about
it mostly because we're talking about
millions of dollars when we passed a two
trillion dollar stimulus package so I
you know I try to look at everything
through a lens of perspective and also
you know I I tried to I tried to
interpret the best of intentions from
from the people who wanted that in there
which was these these particular
organizations like the Kennedy Center
they will shed jobs if we don't fund
them because they they make their money
off of events now the frustrating part
for everybody was they still shed jobs
many days later like many businesses are
I just this this isn't something that
like made me angry you know and I
suppose you since I just wrote a whole
book about about not engaging in an
outrage and having some perspective and
looking a few layers deep into why
something happened as a method to sort
of temper your own emotions so you know
it's it's generally hard to get me
emotionally upset and I don't understand
it from either side of the aisle frankly
when people get emotional about things
it doesn't mean they're wrong to show
concern but I wouldn't let it keep you
up at night
yeah all right so just one more on this
then what else should the government be
doing right now I mean we're all still
in lockdown you know yesterday I went to
my local hardware store and I saw that I
could buy seeds to plant some things
which I did buy but I know that in
Michigan you actually can't buy
seeds right now I mean we've got a
series of kind of crazy things and I'm
all I'm all for the the governors and
the states doing what they want I think
you mostly are as well but there are
some strange things happening but what
do you think the role of the federal
government and the states should be
right now and are they basically working
together pretty well yeah I think the
balance is about right I think every
once in a while even the president says
kind of the wrong thing about you know
whether he's talking about forcing your
reopening or forcing a national lockdown
neither is okay you can't do it that
that's up to the states and in states
like Michigan where the governor is
making up stupid rules they should be
held accountable
I hope voters are holding I think it's a
her right deeply accountable for these
completely foolish policies that are
really just based in virtue signally not
based in any actual even even two
seconds of logical thoughts it's like
what you know I was talking on the phone
with my brother who's stationed and Fort
Bragg and they have a 9:00 p.m. curfew
what on earth is a 9:00 p.m. curfew
doing to stop the spread of a pandemic
bars are already closed this doesn't
make any sense this is just something
for for for simple-minded people to
express how much they did do to combat
the pandemic you didn't do anything you
infringed on people's freedoms for no
reason you have to have a good reason
for implementing the restrictions that
people are going to implement okay so so
what's next into your question well
what's next is we have to start having a
real conversation about how to reopen
the economy alongside battling and and
reducing the risk of the pandemic and
this looks a lot like a what would
Harvard economists and and political
scientists are calling a mobilized in
transition phase I know our governor
here in Texas is going to come out with
his plan soon I think the federal
government is as well I've just written
an op-ed about it and it basically looks
like this look we tweet we have to
dispel this myth that there's a binary
choice between a perpetual lockdown and
just letting people die and the spread
of the pandemic neither of these things
are true you can do both okay and we
have to do both this is not
we have to do and it I think along three
factors the we have to be focused on
testing capacity which we're a little
behind on but I think we can rather
quickly ramp up to the right standard
public health capacity meaning our
hospitals or ventilators or PPE
I think we're I think we're getting to a
much better place on that and and then
public education on how to deal with it
whether that's standing six feet away
from each other wearing a mask to work
you know just making those micro changes
in your life and in your business so
that we can live alongside of pandemic
for for a period of time until there's a
vaccine that's the new normal and it
doesn't involve shutting down the
economy indefinitely
we have been this is the last thing I
want to say I get really worried when we
become obsessive over the nature of the
curve and the peak those are important
data points but they're not V data
points there's other data points like
our sense of preparedness along those
three lines that I just mentioned you
know when I hear when I hear our mayor
talking about how we can't open up
Houston because we haven't reached the
peak yet I find out to be absurd because
if you put our numbers that we have here
in Houston which is very very small like
very very small we're the fourth largest
city in America we barely have any cases
you know comparatively speaking if you
put our numbers and place those in New
York City right now New York City would
be celebrating and they'd open up
everything if that's if that can be true
then it tells you that our logic isn't
correct as we think about what our you
know our goal posts are to open up the
economy and I just I'm encouraging
leaders to think through this a little
bit more deeply yeah it's one of the
reasons actually that I'm kind of
hopeful for the future when we get out
of this that some of the right ideas
that I think you're writing about in
this book will break forth I mean things
like states rights like we're actually
talking about states rights right now
for the first time in this country in
god I don't know maybe since roe v wade
like we never talk about states rights
and suddenly people are like oh
governor's are supposed to do things and
the president doesn't have ultimate
authority and a whole bunch of other
things so since the book is about
American resilience in the air
of outrage one thing on American
resilience related to Corona
specifically are you worried that as
this has gone on and maybe as some of
the states get back to work and some
take longer and it looks like New York
will take a really long time but just
the longer that we're in our houses the
longer that the economy is shut the
longer that we kind of sputter along
that thing the American resilience that
you write about here that's the special
thing we have in America that every
other country wishes they had but the
more that we sort of just let government
do things and oh oh the peak didn't
happen yet we'll stay in our house for
another month like that we'd actually
start forgetting what that spirit of
American resilience is that's what I'm
kind of I see a lot of silver lines here
as a silver linings as I just mentioned
but that's the thing I'm worried about
that over time we would just start
accepting more and more rules and
accepting that more and more experts
know what to do when perhaps they don't
and then you know the bad actors in
government that just sort of want to
control all of us yeah and those are
those are definitely reasonable fears I
think unfortunately the reality is as we
shifted towards that acceptance a long
time ago and I'm actually seeing I think
this entire experience might bring us
back to normalcy to an extent where we
do see that experts don't have all the
answers their data is important their
opinions are important but it takes a
leader to to sift through all of those
opinions and then make a bold decision
and then get people to rally behind that
decision and mobilize we are seeing some
terrible infringement on freedom not so
much that it's not so much a problem for
me that government is telling you to
avoid the beach well that's silly it
doesn't make any practical sense but
right but my point is is like I don't
mind that they're telling you that what
I do mind is that they'll arrest you for
it that that's that's a bridge too far
and and I'm we're not dealing with that
in Texas I know you are in California
and in other places but that's that's
not okay I think you're gonna see some
terrible lawsuits after after all this
is done you know you
have to have the lightest touch possible
there's the the government does have a
place in ensuring public health but with
a light touch and and we're getting it
wrong in some places people are getting
it wrong because there's such a
temptation to keep people safe right
like that's that's what every politician
wants to say the most oven and they say
it because it works and you know to your
point we have to resist that urge as
American too to always want to be kept
safe to believe that is the government's
duty to not just allow us to pursue our
happiness but to make us happy and to
keep us safe at any cost
you know when you see this debate play
out when when people try to genuinely
talk about opening up the economy well
the most disingenuous counter to that is
well how many lives is it worth to you
to save that job that's not the right
question you know it's not a question
because I can I can flip that right back
on you I could say well I'm a more moral
person because I want to keep 40
thousand people a year alive and you
know I'm gonna do that no more driving
it's done driving is done well that's
but that's not reasonable right but I
could but I can make a a completely
objective argument that I would save
that many lives you know and you're not
moral because you're not a good person
because you don't want to agree with me
well that's not how we live our lives we
have risks and we mitigate those risks
and it's time that we'd be bold enough
to confront those risks with the new
tools that we have and now we've in the
way I described the coronavirus issues
we've taken a tactical retreat and and
and and in that tactical retreat which
is you know in sealed terms means we get
shot away from the target all right we
didn't know what hit us
we went die we went back we retreated a
little bit we reload we call in some air
support and then we move back to
confront the enemy there is no perpetual
retreat that would just be failure in
defeat and and that's how we have to
look at this too and you know and I I
have a lot of faith in the American
people on a micro-level to do that what
I'm seeing is a what I'm not seeing is
the ability of our more public
discussions to also engage in that kind
of in that sense of fortitude and and
avoid the political
that we've seen thus far yeah well
listen that's why I've got you on right
now so let's fix it let's fix it
together so let's go back to the
beginning the thing that sort of made
you a national figure although you were
a congressman already let's talk about
Saturday Night Live I'm sure you've
never talked about that before right you
maybe maybe once maybe twice can you
just talk a little bit about that night
you see you see the Pete Davidson sketch
and then just sort of all the fallout
and then what you did ultimately was it
literally I think the next week when you
when you went on the show and just talk
about how that then sort of set you up
to be a more national figure instead of
just a you know a congressman from from
Texas yeah well obviously I wasn't I
wasn't really watching it that night of
course you know nobody is I think most
people digest the most people digest
Saturday Night Live from like the next
day's YouTube videos or something if
it's a good skit and that's that was no
different on this one of course the
story started getting written about it I
had not seen it I had some funny text
messages from my buddies that were just
giving me a hard time for it you know we
have a very dark sense of humor and the
teams and it became apparent rather
quickly that that it was a bigger deal
than maybe I thought because it I was
mostly just annoyed that that I had to
deal with it at all
there was a was there was a lot going on
that day it was the Sunday before the
election you know we were doing pretty
well but it but I had a lot of events I
had to get to and it felt more like an
annoyance I was not I was not used to
having to respond publicly to things
probably the way I'm more used to that
now 22 people the one sentence recap of
what the skit was or what the line was
there sure so yeah Pete Davidson was
basically going down a list of
quote-unquote gross people all
politicians all all except for one were
Republican and he basically just makes
fun of everybody but with me he you know
at first he's like this guy he looks
kind of like a hit man in a porno and
that was pretty funny to be honest sorry
like you know he lost his eye or
whatever right and it was that it was
that single line that that seems so
dismissive
of a war injury that just injure people
nuts and and understandably so and now
the way I analyzed this and the way I
analyzed it in my book is is it was
pretty obvious that he was trying to
take a dig at conservatives right it is
it's the Davidson it's Saturday Night
Live it they did get Democrats plenty
too but but on this particular skit it
was a very clear swipe at conservatives
because the it's obvious just just watch
it it was not it was obvious that that
he was trying to insult wounded veterans
you know and so there was there was the
thought process the next day was okay
how much grace can we give here while
still while still acknowledging that
many veterans are hurt by this like
genuinely they're pissed off and maybe
they have a good reason to be but also I
don't know when leash this outrage mob
because one I don't feel it you know I I
just I genuinely don't feel like this
sense of being offended and it's just
not who I am and so I don't know express
something that I'm not really feeling
either which seems to be the norm and
the surprising thing about all this was
that it was so surprising to people
that'd that I wouldn't unleash the
outraged mob and I said something no my
main quote from that was you know a
quote that I actually stole from a
Harvard professor which was try hard not
to offend people try even harder not to
be offended you know the joke wasn't
very funny but like I'm not gonna call
for this guy to get fired I'm not gonna
like I'm you know demand that everybody
cancels Saturday Night Live it's just it
seems it's that felt wrong and so we
didn't do it and that gave Saturday
Night Live the space to actually
apologize the way they wanted to and
have me on and I talked about this in my
tribal chapter about the right sense of
shame mm-hmm and this is the only time I
bring up the Saturday Night Live thing
in the book that the book kind of came
about because of the fame that I got
from Saturday Night Live but the book
isn't really about that it's just it
just so happens that I I was directly
involved in sort of an outraged culture
moment and so I decided to write a whole
book about the solutions
outrage culture and but that moment it
takes up like three pages in the book
not even but what I point out is that
there's a right way to show shame in our
culture and there's a wrong way and more
and more and more our culture is going
the wrong way where we have like these
two extreme options on the one hand
people will bow down to the outraged mob
I'm so sorry I can't believe I did that
and I bring up some examples in the book
on that one one because this one just
drove me nuts was Mario Lopez when he
makes the all too understandable comment
that three-year-olds should not choose
their gender I mean oh my god can't even
be even believe he said that right and
then but what does he do he doesn't say
hey hold on what's wrong with that you
know come on guys he says oh my god I'm
so sorry I'm so so sorry please please
forgive me right that's the wrong sense
of shame and there's on the other
extreme there's another wrong sense of
shame which is showing no shame at all
mm-hmm and there's plenty of examples
like that mostly in the political world
but other but in other places as well
and other public figures and then I
diagnose like the why is that why is
there this incentive for one or the
other and it's and it's in all of us
problem it's not just our terrible
politicians or silly celebrities it's in
all of us problem we all engage in this
shaming in the wrong way we either we
overreact to such an extent that we
force people to bow down when they
shouldn't or we overreact to such an
extent that public figures realize
there's no incentive to apologize
because there's no forgiving there's no
huge no redemption there's no forgetting
like and so we have to get back to this
sort of middle ground and people and
there's good examples that I bring up in
the book of that good middle ground too
and we don't do we just have to do more
of that be more nuanced than our
thinking nuance is like a huge part of
solving this problem yeah
so you you go back on SNL and there's
humor and there's nuance and decency and
all of those things and that kind of
propels you and one of the things things
that I think is sort of interesting
about you is it's like we've sort of got
these cartoons
characters on the left with the squad
like AOC and Ilan Omar and to leave and
a couple others and then there's sort of
you on the other side of that and when
you when you take you and and the
eyepatch they're sort of like you're
kind of like Nick Fury like if we're
looking at this through a marbled lens
it's like we should as we should right I
mean but I mean we're sort of like
there's like all the politicians now
it's soil and Trump and everybody it's
sort of like characters in a movie or in
a video game or something like that but
I mentioned this because it's like it
seems like there's this young crew from
the lefties and then there's sort of you
on the other side of that are there some
other guys that you got guys girls
whatever that that you think are in your
crew that are sort of the younger more
get it more willing to open up talk
about these things I mean you know I've
done events with you where like you know
you can be out there with the students
and and it's not this stuffy thing but
it seems like it's kind of just you
holding that for the for the sort of new
more may be open-minded conservative
something like that yeah that's a good
question I do get asked that a lot and
it's a difficult question because like I
don't want to try and analyze the minds
of my colleagues who who maybe don't put
themselves out there as much I think
maybe a lot would be willing to but they
don't have the same ability to or
they're not sure how there's some really
great members of Congress who are our
age you know like Mike Gallagher Elise
Stefanik
and they're out there but you know they
they have their own style they're not on
social media the way I am they're not
out there the way I am everybody does
have their own style I'm excited about
sort of a new squad coming out of Texas
we've got a lot of great new candidates
running very diverse set very young I'm
really excited about it you know I've
got Wesley hunt here next to me
african-american army helicopter pilot
got Tony Gonzales running for will heard
see old Master Chief not not old sorry
but prior Master Chief you know Beth Van
Dyne she's a prior mayor again young
like got a lot of very intelligent got a
lot of spunk
Genevieve Collins another great one
again young woman
millennial like me you know very
successful got a great shot at that see
if there's there's a lot of really good
candidates and I I think the Republican
Party does have a chance to like really
remake itself in a really big way that
that connects with a lot of different
people so I'm I'm excited about it yeah
is the biggest challenge they're just
getting over sort of the old stereotypes
I mean just the old stereotypes
conservatives care about money and care
about war and you know Democrats like
poor people and peace like these basic
sort of very factory setting things when
when in reality I mean we spoke at the
turning-point student action summit and
and Trump spoke that morning and it was
right after the the impeachment hearing
and you wanted to get up in the middle
of his speech you were trying to show
him your vote that you voted against it
and it was like it was a totally
impromptu moment Trump looks at you in
the crowd he's like damn come on up here
the secret the Secret Service guys are
all looking like Oh God now we have to
get this guy from the crowd even though
he's a congressman get him on stage but
but he my my broader point is that it
was like fun and real which is so the
reverse of what politics is presented to
us as yeah
oh yeah I mean it's totally changed in
the last few years and I think it's
exciting now we have to be responsible
with with how we manage this new train
that's just like lurching forward right
because it is this sort of interesting
combination of like showmanship with
with some deep thinking and some some
real actual statesmanship it is up to us
as leaders to make sure that we that we
maintain those bonds and and then that
balance in a very coherent way and
that's what I try to do that that's why
I do more than just the showy stuff you
know we we've got to have fun and we got
to we can happen we also have to show
them deeply and not fall into that very
simplistic mindset that you and we're
you know these guys are four people in
these guys are for rich people right and
like you're totally right there's these
stereotypes that we have to resist and
and move past and for too on the
Republican
unable to do that because we didn't
quite take the time to understand the
left I think and I think what I'm
excited about the younger generation of
conservatives takes a lot more time to
try and understand the left and and how
they think maybe what even their what
their what their write about but have
but how to confront their policies
subscriptions or prescriptions to those
problems that they that they that they
try to expose and in thinking more
deeply about our foundations about why
we think what we think young people
especially because they're so well
informed you know and that's a careful
word to use because like their informs
but they don't have experience with
which to with which to process a lot of
that information but generally what you
see what young people is they want more
information they want to listen to an
hour-long podcast they they they want a
deeper explanation not just a talking
point of why you're saying what you're
saying which is why do these here's the
truth videos and you know I still have
to make them really short because it's
social media like III see the percentage
of the people watch it's not but still
it's still short
I also do a podcast for the same reason
so that I can access the people that way
as well you got to meet people where
they're at and so that is the new future
of politics you've got a it's not just
getting that news hit or getting that
op-ed written because again only certain
people read that stuff at least they're
people watch that stuff everybody else
is over here on YouTube Instagram then
you got your Facebook crap and you just
got it to be everywhere if you want to
be effective so I love the inner flap of
the book it says Jordan Peterson's 12
rules for life meets Jocko willing and
leaf bobbins extreme ownership in this
tough love leadership book from a Navy
SEAL and rising star in Republican
politics so obviously you know I know
Jordan quite well and of course I've had
Jacqueline as well was that sort of the
the idea there to fuse together these
people that were sort of about putting
your life together first and then also
blending your experience being in the
Navy now being in politics or being a
seal now being in politics that it's
it's about sort of fixing yourself first
which is very consistently a Jordan type
message
it is and you know what we probably I
think the the the fact that it did
become this this combination of Jordans
book with with life and and Jacko's book
that was a bit more of a an
after-the-fact five it but that was the
point for sure and I and I and I think
that's a very accurate description of it
I'm not quite sure that I would call it
a leadership book I might at that little
part out on the next next synagogue is
the next round it's it's fundamentally a
mental resilience book and how to be a
stronger person and therefore a stronger
culture and so it's it's meant to be
both it's meant to be a personal journey
but as well as a cultural journey I I am
fighting the culture war in this book as
well you know this this cultural war
against victimhood ideology like that's
a prevalent theme throughout the book
but I'm also I'm also bringing it down
to very practical terms to your daily
life and but but I'm also doing so with
with you know not quite the extensive
philosophical underpinnings that Jordan
Peterson does but I'm still doing that
and I'm still diving into psych
psychological research and all the
literature to back up what I'm saying
because what I one thing I point out in
the book quite often is these are not
new ideas but that's kind of the point
the best ideas are the old ideas they've
been around the longest for a very good
reason they've been through trial and
error they've been passed down for
generations because they work personal
responsibility is the tenant of our is a
cultural foundation because it works
because it means all of these things
that are very important for a society to
thrive you know thinking through your
emotions before you react that that's
and that's an old piece of advice like
your mom said count to 10 before you
start to say something like these are
this is a reason that these sort of
idioms
exist in our culture because they're old
and they work I referenced the Bible
quite a bit in the book because wow it's
like these ideas they're not new they're
not new and then they're backed up by
science they're backed up by our
intuition they're backed up by personal
experience and so I I wanted to write
because my mind goes a lot of differ
directions and so I wanted to write this
sort of multidisciplinary book and then
try to draw those disciplines together
in a single theme with that is that is
simultaneously very entertaining and
also speaks to people in a modern way
too because I've referenced pop culture
a lot of reference movies a lot
reference people that you would know in
politics a lot not until the end of the
book do I really get into a I think a
political philosophy discussion telling
you saying are you saying that people
before you and before me actually had
good ideas and we should possibly listen
to maybe the founders and and people
even before that but maybe helped us get
here and it shouldn't just be whatever
we think on any on any given day and
that our grandparents were in all idiots
are you saying that I might be saying
that yeah conservatism means gratitude
it's gratitude for things that work like
philosophies that work cultural
foundations that work policies that work
I
we're meaning to conserve anything it's
conserving the things that work and what
the left fundamentally stands for is is
radical change you know this this this
sort of reaching for utopia this
constant reach for utopia and and a
constant tearing down of our current
status in order to justify the really
extreme measures that they need to take
in order to get to this supposed utopia
and that's dangerous it's dangerous
because it leaves out so much in the
equation like like how did you almost
get to the utopia in the first place
because you have to admit we have it
better than anybody ever in history
doesn't mean things are perfect but that
is the nature of our of our being you
know and what is perfect look like you
know so these are these are deep
questions but they but they treat them
as if they're not that's the problem
with the day these are these are very
fundamental questions but they treat
them very casually and and conservatives
are the ones that sit hold on guys like
think think through this think of the
second third order effects of what
you're saying when when you when you
want to implement something simple like
a fifteen dollar minimum
you know if there's there's deeper
consequences to every action you take
and in conservatives I think fight to to
recognize those things so as a guy that
has fought in actual Wars and then you
referenced the the culture war a couple
times here what are some of the lessons
you learn just through discipline and
training and everything else through
through actual physical war versus the
sort of war that you're fighting on the
ideological front now well every job
I've had there's somebody who threatens
to kill me like hasn't changed all that
much dark humor yeah it's just real war
you know so to speak is is very honest
your your your decisions your attention
to detail they have these life or death
consequences the the culture war is it's
it's less honest it's it's it's about
opportunism oftentimes the political
warfare is about opportunism for sure
it's about it's about trying to
interpret the worst of intentions but
based on your opponents actions even if
that's not what they meant it's it's
it's it's it's it's a bloodsport none of
itself just not literal blood and and so
that and that was the premise for a lot
of me wanting to write this book because
I see how damaging that is it's it's
it's causing anxiety on a micro level
it's causing people to see the doctor
more it's make you upset you know you
see these happy people but like how
could a happy person right we you just
wrote on Twitter that's a terrible thing
to say and what is going on here you
know and and and and why why are
students
so upset why do they feel like there's
like their physical safety is in
jeopardy just because somebody's
speaking an idea that they don't like
that's a that's a really strange thing
and and you know I I don't diagnose that
problem too much in my book that I leave
that to better authors and I just
referenced their work because
fundamentally I'm trying to find the
solutions to that I'm trying to I'm
trying to I'm hoping that one I'm hoping
that the people I'm describing
actually read the book instead of the
people who are generally probably don't
need the bush for the ones buying it but
um but I'm hoping that one thing will
speak to you and just and just cause you
to sort of shift your thinking on
something and maybe see some of that
problem in yourself and you didn't even
realize it and and change accordingly I
know I mean even writing the book like I
probably figured some things out about
myself you know this this book is not
how about how perfect I am geez I just I
just happened to write about the
standards by which I think I should live
as someone that just finished my first
book - I hear you like it actually it
unearths stuff within you and that's
actually the cool part so for so I know
we could agree on most of our
frustrations with the left all day long
and we could talk about it for you know
20 hours in a row no problem what would
you say are some of the the frustrations
that you have with say your side or the
conservative movement or the Republican
Party and when when you talk to somebody
like me who you know we have some
political disagreements do you think
there is like how wide do you think that
10 on the right can get without losing
those core principles like you know I've
had people like Heather McDonald on the
show from the Manhattan Institute who's
a totally secular conservative she's an
atheist conservative but a lot of
conservatives think oh no there has to
be a religious attachment or is there
even any room for you know I describe
myself as bruh grudgingly pro-choice and
I get into it in the book pretty heavily
but is there like how do you figure out
what room there is on this side for
people that have sort of marginal
differences let's say butts but mostly
believe in individual rights liberty
freedom all the stuff that really is the
important stuff in that's an eternally
debated question I don't know that I
have a great answer for it that it
largely depends I think on your own
temperament and my personal temperament
is I'm certainly more accepting of
people who disagree with you know ten
percent of my views and say that the
fine that it still still makes you a
Republican I'm not going to yell and
scream at you because we disagree on a
couple of things here and there I I
think it's
possible to wrap conservative ideology
in into most of our views and it takes
it I think a sophisticated thinker to go
through that when you ask my
frustrations with with conservatives
it's it's many I what I point out in the
book a lot is I try to be fair as pot as
fair as possible as far as I can in the
book when I am when I'm criticizing
liberals and I also criticize
conservatives if I have a if I have a
liberal politician example of something
bad that happened try to have a
conservative one as well to point out
it's the same as it pertains to outraged
culture specifically with with this
tendency to to elevate passion and
emotion above sophistication you know
it's like replacing replacing
sophisticated arguments with attitude
you know like I have a problem with that
and and conservative certainly do it so
where does Trump what where does Trump
fall into that for you then because I
know you you are a I always hate the
phrase Trump supporter it's like people
you want to support the president he's
flying the plane we don't want this
plane to crash but I mean I was a guy
that basically you like Trump you
support his agenda pretty much from what
I can tell where did where does he
factor in exactly what you just said
they're not exactly with what I just
said I mean he's definitely he's not
perfect right like his style gets in his
own way for sure and it's not my style
but but as far as specifically tying it
to what I just said that's more
prevalent among activists to to like try
and on the left like in this like kind
of disingenuous way it's sometimes it's
not disingenuous sometimes it's a gray
tone okay but we just have to be smart
enough to distinguish between the two
and and and sometimes I see us not
distinguishing correctly like if I can
counter argue if I can immediately say
what the left would say to that argument
then you haven't thought through your
argument very well and like you know you
you want to this is why I like ben
shapiro so much because he's very air
tight with his argumentation you you
have to anticipate what the other side
is gonna say that's what makes you good
right because
because you're right because you're
because you're actually directly
confronting what the other side is
saying as opposed to building a straw
man argument and when I say elevate
passion above substance generally
speaking it means kind of making a
disingenuous straw man argument and like
maybe I've done it I'm sure I have but
we should avoid it we should avoid it
and what I also talked about in my book
is I'm not mad that that happens I guess
what frustrates me is that that's what
gets the most clicks mm-hmm you know we
sort of and I talked about this in a
chapter it's a really deep discussion I
think I don't know if Jordan Peterson
would agree because he's like how can
you be deeper than Jordan Peterson but
it's about but it's actually about
something that he talks about quite a
bit which is hero archetypes and what we
view is good and like that's that's a
good place to start
you know if we're trying to be better
well we have to define what better
actually looks like and what works and
so what we've done in our culture is you
sort of elevated the wrong heroes over
time like we've elevated victims instead
of victors and and I use Superman as an
example of like this sort of heroic
archetype that we should look up to you
know Jesus is a hero that we look up to
it's like everything he did was just
perfect these days these days Superman
would have to be a victim that right if
we were to actually look at him as a
hero then he would have to have been
victimized in some way and like so
there's a real change there and there's
a change of what we view as good and as
it pertains to that sort of extra
attitude passionates own the libs type
thinking well shouldn't we be elevating
the smartest person in the room
shouldn't we be elevating the think-tank
piece that just in detailed debunks what
the other side thinks on a given policy
but that doesn't get any clicks and I
get it it's not emotional it's not fun
it's not entertaining but maybe we
should rethink that maybe we should be
giving these think tanks a little bit
more juice you know instead of instead
of our you know our or activists who you
know have the snarky as' comment and I'm
not again I'm not I'm not despair
the importance and the fun behind a lot
of the memes that we like make and share
I share them too I just I just want us
to think twice and just to balance it
out yeah it's funny because when I when
I've been asked something like that I
think of it you know from in a war
perspective it's like the memes and some
of that that's like the ground troops
the ideas is the Air Force like you do
need to hit this from a multi-pronged
approach so it all sort of is part of it
so we've talked this far about outrage
and culture war and everything else and
we haven't really mentioned the media at
all now you know my feelings about most
of the mainstream media I think you
share many of my opinions right now as
it stands what do you make of what is
left of the mainstream media does it
even matter anymore partly I think it's
just sort of the show must go on like
it's the last thing that keeps us all
cohesive as a nation to have something
thought of as mainstream otherwise we
would all completely splinter off into
our own echo chambers and our own
ideologies and all that is is there
anything that can be redeemed when you
see what the New York Times is up to
what CNN is up to is it worth redeeming
or do we just need new institutions you
know I had Dana Perino on my podcast
last week and I was really pressing her
on this question about the behavior of
the media and she was really pushing
back against me which I wasn't quite
expecting and she felt obliged to
rightfully point out to me that there's
there's a lot of other media right and
it's not just the CNN and MSNBC which
are which are truly in an information
warfare against the president but that's
that's what that's what they see their
mission as the New York Times similar
similarly Washington Post in this
somewhat more balanced but but overall
the same thing but what she had to point
out to me was like there's all these
other shows or networks know what's the
right I'm gonna screw up the exact
terminology but it's like the difference
between cable and broadcast I'm not
really sure but you know like ABC at NBC
and CBS and she's like and she and she
sent me this Wall Street Journal article
I think that came out today
and The Wall Street Journal article says
Wow look what happens when you watch
these other programs for 22 minutes I
mean any given day in America like and
then they point to CBS not not that any
of these are faultless like these
organizations screw up too but for the
most part as this as this Wall Street
Journal article emphasizes they're just
talking about American stories across
the entirety of America you know a
business owner that just lost lost
everything somebody whose father just
died of kovat 19 like just American
stories that and they don't really
mention Trump throughout any of this
reporting and I thought that's really
interesting and maybe that's the sense
of perspective that I need because you
know maybe I don't see that as much
because I live in this sort of political
bubble and I I just you know I I think
what we need in America is better
definitions and clear lines between left
and right wing media and between opinion
journalism and news and if we can
collectively educate ourselves on the
differences and and if journalists can
be responsible enough to to kind of
self-report what they're actually doing
and who they're actually representing I
think that might go a long way yeah I
think you're probably a little more
hopeful for some sort of resurrection
than I am I'm also I'm also worried just
because you know young people just don't
watch the NBC Nightly News or the ABC
nightly news or CBS Nightly News so they
might be more fair I'm actually not
saying they aren't but I just don't know
any 22 year old if I was to poll at any
event that I went to you know who's
watching Lester Holt on NBC I just don't
know they're not watching Fox either
yeah conservatives aren't watching fox
or MSNBC it's it's they're watching
they're watching this show on YouTube
and they're watching they're look at my
Instagram account so yeah that goes back
when I was a poor you got to meet
everybody where they're at yeah so give
me I know no politician likes being in
the the prediction game but sort of try
to lay out the next couple months as we
roll into this this coming election I
think we still have an election coming
it hasn't been canceled yet God knows
what's gonna happen
Biden well actually let's just talk
about that for a minute what do you make
of what has happened here with with the
Democrats and that ultimately you know
everybody fell in line behind by it and
as we're taping this right now Obama
finally did endorse you know way later
than it seemed sensible I mean truly do
you think Biden has the mental capacity
to do this and do you think the DNC is
just sitting there with some card in
their back pocket that either is the VP
replaces him at the convention or right
after which would be the most you know
right after an inauguration potentially
which would be the most perverse thing
but at this point it's like I feel like
all rules are off that's that's sort of
where I'm at with them at this point
oh the second question is fascinating I
just have no idea I mean if I were them
I would be thinking of a way to do that
yeah I mean right yeah because the
answer your first question there's
there's been a very clear decline it
happened very recently you know when you
have no pressure on you all you have to
do is go down to your game room or study
or whatever he's filming in and and and
simply look like a leader with no
responsibility on your shoulders at all
that that's that's I can't imagine an
easier thing to do but he can't do it
he's not making any sense when he's when
he's speaking about things that he
should really understand and should she
be able to talk about you know add to
that a very disingenuous criticisms that
he's often leveling are usually just
things that he says he would do better
but they're things the administration is
already doing that's a more substantive
argument but but but as part of the
decline it's very clearly happening and
that they can't ignore that that being
said if they were to try to disrupt that
at the convention I mean if I'm then if
I'm a fly on the wall and they're in
their strategy session I'm sure they're
they're weighing that option but the
problem is if they do that how does that
other person gain any momentum in time
to actually win the election and the
question of are you still gonna have
elections yes I I believe we will I mean
we should have
be prepared for another uptick in cases
in November because it will be fall but
I think will be better I think we'll be
well-prepared for it and and I hope I
hope that American resilience shows
through we have to be willing to live
with risk we have to stop listening to
politicians that tell us that when the
flattening of the curve all of a sudden
there's no risk that's not going to be
true until there's a vaccine like this
this is this is real like this this is a
real thing in our history that we are
fighting and and we can do it we just
got to be smart about it
this idea that we need to completely
revamp our election system to to have to
have an election and to have only
mail-in ballots for everybody across
America I find that argument to be a bit
absurd I'm only bringing it up because I
want to give your viewers the the simple
counter-argument to that when a Democrat
demands that everybody does mail-in
ballots ask them a very simple question
functionally speaking what is the
difference between standing in line at
the grocery store and standing in line
to vote mm-hmm is there any difference
no there's not there's just not you know
what's easier six making sure that
people stand six feet away from each
other and sanitize the screen that they
use to vote or the piece of or the
pencil that they use to vote or
completely revamping our entire election
system right and also when you hear them
talk about this I mean Ilhan Omer has
been tweeting up a storm about this that
we should have mail-in voting I mean I'm
pretty sure she's against having ID to
vote in the first place so how so what
can you can you not have an ID and still
mail in a vote I mean what are you even
how in the world are you possibly even
pretending to be who you are at that
point you know you mean right it's it's
it's so absurd and now it of course
that's the other counter-argument it's
okay can you fine make then everybody
has to register in person at some point
between now and then with with a with an
ID and of course they'll say know it
which is that's the strangest thing
racist isn't that racist that's what
they say the voter ID debate is just
it's one of the strangest coming out of
the left and it's so utterly strange
they want so many rules and regulations
around so many things in our life but
this one thing this one thing that
matters it's such a huge extent they
want it to basically be all that no not
let's just let's just trust everybody
and let's just basically
they wanted as easy as like you know
ordering a coffee on your phone we
should be able to vote that easily they
they see voting totally differently and
it's hard to imagine why except that
they want you know that I will won't go
there I will I won't try to to interpret
their intentions but no but I think but
I think everyone's thinking exactly what
you were about to say how about I'll say
it right I mean you can either not or
you could cover your camera but the
basic idea being that they want illegals
to vote or they want people to be able
to double vote for their people or the
rest of it I mean there can't be because
I know what you're trying to give them
the best of intentions here right like
that's exactly what you were just saying
and yet it seems fairly obvious it's
like these they believe in driver's
licenses they believe in licenses if you
want to become a beautician or cut
somebody's hair but for some reason with
this one thing that's like the core
thing for democracy it's so weird it's
so weird because because I mean you've
seen probably plenty of videos where
somebody will go out into a minority
neighborhood and just start asking
everybody if they have an ID and
everybody's like of course it I why are
you asking me that what's wrong with you
well of course I have an ID how would I
live without an ID everybody has an ID
you got an ID to get on a plane to buy a
rated-r movie ticket if you walk up to
the booth at the theater I mean come on
it's it the Democrats are very good it
gets a voter ID and and any kind of
rules or regulations around voting they
get in the way here's the best possible
interpretation of their intentions it
gets in the way of what they are good at
with respect to ballot harvesting with
respect to getting a lot of people on a
bus and moving them to the voting polls
like they're very good at this remember
the old Democratic Party was a Labour
Party so they were good at unionizing
they were good at activating where we've
never been good at that as Republicans
it's not really in our nature but
Democrats are activists by Nature which
is the problem with their entire
governing philosophy by the way you
can't have a governing philosophy based
on basically activism that's a different
discussion it's a deeper discussion but
they're good at certain things and if
you put
basic rules around this institution of
Elections those things become harder to
do and so it's it's it's really about
they really are playing for advantage in
that sense
all right well congressman Dan Crenshaw
I'm glad we finally did this
unfortunately
digitally but we will do it in person
eventually the book is fortitude we're
gonna link to it right down below and
stay safe and we need you out there so
you really got to stay safe I'm not just
saying it like you where you're one of
the few guys we need so really six
beeping everybody all right I've been
through worse if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell